[Music]
um
let's move on to the next one this comes
from brother carlington he says how many
prophecies are left to be fulfilled
besides the national sunday law
well we have the loud cry has to be
given
the full outpouring of the
the latter end when i see it full the
latvian is certainly falling on
individuals but the full outpouring of
god's people so they can work as a
people has not yet happened um we have
the uh the club of probation has not yet
happened the little time of trouble has
not yet happened the great time of
trouble has not yet happened
um the death penalty has not yet
happened
the several last place have not yet
happened all these things have not yet
happened
but you're alive today
live for god today
you may not see these things happen at
all live for god today but all these
things have not yet happened but that
does not mean they are far off because
they have not happened something can
happen tomorrow so these things have not
yet happened according to the chronology
of prophetic events
amen and although this question was on
act someone sent me a message and wanted
to know if the vials or like the seven
trumpets that that sounded if those are
in the future or if those already came
to pass i believe those are the the
shofars that are sounded in revelation
chapter
uh
16 but from what my understanding is
they're incomplete fulfillments of
judgment whereas the seven last plagues
are complete would you be able to give
some clarity on that the seven last
plays are complete yes um the seven
trumpets they have begun to sound
they're referring to historical events
the seven seals also were opened in a
certain order referring to uh the
spiritual development of the church uh
the seven trumpets political social
events occurring contemporary
contemporaneously with the development
of the church so there are they have
been sounding and we still have the
seven the six and the seven the seventh
trumpet to sound
because christ is coming under the
seventh
amen thank you all the skeet
you